ما بين شرق روسي وغرب اوكراني نهر يفصل
بينهما وسد غير مجرى المعارك انهيار سنوبك
خوفك الواقع على نهر دينيبرو لكن السؤال
الابرز من المستفيد الاكبر في هذه الحاله
لنبدا من الجانب الروسي الذي نفى ان يكون
له يد في ذلك كيف له ان يؤلم نفسه بنفسه
اولا انهيار سد نوفاك خوفك يعني ان المياه
ستتدفق من مجرى مع مجرى النهر اي باتجاه
الشرق الذي تتمركز فيه القوات الروسيه
وتشم ضرباتها منه وبالتالي ستضطر القوات
الروسيه لاجلاء قواتها وسكانها بعيدا عن
خيرسون احد اسخر النقاط الاستراتيجيه في
الحرب اما ثانيا فلما قد تقطع روسيا
امدادات المياه لشبه جزيره القرم التي
ترتوي من ذلك السد
[موسيقى]
لا اجابه وافيه ولكن بالنظر الى تاريخ
الدب الروسي نفت القوات السوفي او نسفت
القوات السوفيتيه انذاك سدا على دينيبرو
ايضا منذ نحو قرن وضحت بالالاف مقابل عدم
تقدم النازيين اما اوكرانيا المنصبه على
التخطيط لهجومها المضاد يبدو انها رات ان
لا سبيل لذلك سوى ان تكسر القبض الروسي
الخانقه على مساحه واسعه من اراضيها بمعنى
اخر وان كانت اصبحت الضفه الشرقيه منطقه
محظوره على الدروع الاوكرانيه الا انها
حتى وقبل تفجير السد كانت عمليه محفوفه
بالمخاطر وتتطلب تكتيكات برمائيه للعبور
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات